this is a strange time of year because
18 teams are done 14 teams are playing
and for the 18
teams that are done now a third of them
are looking for coaches and we already
knew
going into yesterday of three vacancies
detroit
atlanta houston the jets joined that
group
last night when they fired adam gase and
then today
two more that were expected to happen
happened
let's start with anthony lynn the
chargers coach
33 and 31 in four seasons was 12 and
four
in 2018 made it to the divisional round
of the playoffs upset
the ravens on the road in the wild card
round of the playoffs
but a disappointment in 2019
this year a disappointment and also
too many mistakes too many opportunities
to criticize him you know when you're
the head coach you're the guy who's in
charge of managing the game and
everything else shireen
when those mistakes are happening it
falls on you and it's at a certain point
it reaches a critical mass
and it's just not sustainable and i
think the chargers realized during the
season
it wasn't sustainable out of respect to
him
no leaks no discussion no anything they
just put a pin in it until the season
was over
let him get through the season don't
create any distractions for him
respect him that way but the day after
the season ended that was that
mike the hard thing is when you're a
really bad team
and you draft a quarterback high you're
usually
on notice the next year anyway and then
the coach gets fired and then that
quarterback has to start over again with
the head coach and an offensive
coordinator in a new system
and we've seen it so many times and
we're seeing it again unfortunately to
justin herbert
in this system he's going to have to
start over again with a new head coach a
new offensive coordinator and a new
system
and i'm not going to say that it's going
to set him back because he looked really
good as a rookie but it's really hard on
these young quarterbacks to have to do
that year after year after year you see
salt with baker mayfield i mean you name
you can name them there's tons of them
who this has happened to
and it he's not going to be the last one
it happens to and he's not the only one
this year frankly that it's happened to
but it's unfortunate for him that he
won't be in the same system this
next year but you saw it coming from the
the clock management the game management
and the losses in the one score games
and giving up leads of 17 points
which anthony lynn did consistently over
the last two years anthony lam was 12
and 20. it was time to go
we all like anthony lynn the chargers
like anthony lynn
he didn't get the job done over the last
two seasons it's time to move on to
somebody else because this
is a team that's ready to win and i know
bill parcells has always said
you are what your record says you are in
this case i think the chargers are
better than what their record
says they are based on those one-score
losses and this is a team
that's going to be a contender for the
postseason next year
this is a team that's had way too many
close games over the past several years
even when they were 12 and four i
remember philip rivers saying the summer
after that
we could have been 16-0 we could have
been six and ten
and if you're truly going to become a
great team it's not just
every week keep it close and hope that
it ultimately
goes your way that was the way brad
childress ran the vikings
it was keep it close keep it close keep
it close wait for a break late in the
game make a break late in the game try
to avoid that break being made against
you
and that's a recipe for eight and eight
that's a recipe for over the long haul
winning as many as you lose in the nfl
you have to find that edge where you are
winning games by more than a score
where you are dominating it's not easy
to do but the bills have found it with
josh allen
and the chargers have their josh allen
in justin herbert the challenge now is
to build around him that's
going to be part of what tom telesco the
gm of the team has to do
but it also is going to be incumbent on
the coach to win with that talent
because they have a lot of talent
and the other thing with the chargers
and i don't think it's enough to just
hire a new coach
i got too many injuries and anytime
there's a team that has
an injury problem at some point i
say where do you start looking at
medical staff training staff strength
and conditioning
because when you watch all the games at
once on a given sunday
you see plenty of guys get pretzeled up
in a way that makes you think they're
not getting up
and they get up so there is something to
be said
for pliability as tom brady would say or
whatever
it is that allows you to take the
physical abuse that happens on a
football field and not have something
break fracture sprain strain whatever
and when you have a lot of injuries i
think that
you're doing something wrong by way of
getting you guys ready to be out on the
field so i would take a close look at
that if i was the chargers that's been
one of their issues in recent years but
they've done the hard part they've
gotten the quarterback shireen and i
think that makes it an attractive job
which also makes it an important hire
because they're going to have
options a ton of options and i'd say
behind the jaguars job that we're going
to talk about in a minute i'd say the
chargers is the second most attractive
i love this job they were ninth in
offense and tenth in defense one of only
a handful of teams that finished
in the top ten in both offense and
defense this is a team that's ready to
win now based on what justin herbert did
this season
setting the rookie record for touchdown
setting the rookie record for
completions he was really good they just
couldn't win those one score game
seven of them they lost and you talked
about the injuries another problem
they've had and they reassigned their
special teams coach during the season
but it didn't work
is special teams this has been a really
bad special teams unit
and when they're this bad you realize
how much special meat teams mean to a
team
they missed 12 field goals mike this
year and they had one return for
touchdown they were last in net punting
i mean they were
awful on special teams and that will
kill a team
it doesn't show up all the time when
your special teams are just
kind of mediocre but when they're really
bad it shows up and it hurts you
especially when you're playing all these
one score games
they've got to get special teams right
they've got to get their injuries right
other than that this to me just looks
like one of the best job openings i mean
you're playing in a great new stadium
you're playing your coaching in la who
wouldn't want to go there and you've got
at the core of a team in place that is
ready to win now
and anytime you've got a head coach who
personally takes over special teams
duties during the season that means your
special teams
are a complete and total mess because of
all the things a head coach has to do
that's the dirty work that he'd rather
not do that he doesn't have time to do
that does take more time and care
than any head coach should have the time
to devote to it and it takes away from
from your bigger picture decision making
and management of the team and all the
things that a head coach has to do well
the chargers will be looking for a head
coach now one drawback to that job
you're in the same
division as patrick mahomes and will be
for the next decade or longer but at
least it's a head coaching job
and at least you have a guy that can be
groomed into a great quarterback
the jaguars in the afc south a more
competitive division
they move on from doug maron who
accomplished the rare feat of losing 15
games in a row in the same season
the 2001 panthers did that they won the
first game of the year then lost 15 in a
row and obviously the 2008 lions in 2017
browns did that and losing 16
in a row but marone is out 12 and 36 in
the last three seasons after winning the
afc south in 2017 and getting on the
brink of
super bowl 52 dave caldwell the gm's
already out
the name that has bubbled to the surface
and and
and if this is some sort of a test that
the jaguars were
implementing to see how discreet urban
meyer is he's failed
because as a result of urban meyer
talking to a lot of different people
who he possibly would hire to be on his
staff or to serve as the gm
because urban meyer apparently will be
hiring the gm in jacksonville if he
takes the job
it's become an open secret that that job
goes to urban meyer
if he wants it and that cat's so far out
of the bag
that if if it wasn't accurate the
jaguars need to come out and disavow
that's how that's how rampant the
reporting and the rumors are
that it's urban meyer's job if he wants
it
now that kind of turns the rooney rule
on its head
and uh it it doesn't show the kind of
discretion and care that i think the nfl
wants its teams to demonstrate
in a year where there's going to be some
pressure
number one to over comply with the
rooney rule and ultimately
pressure on teams to improve the total
numbers because the numbers got to a
point last year where it created a
discussion point for months
shireen but in jacksonville it looks
like meyer's the guy you could argue the
fact that they fired marone means that
they think they're getting urban meyer
because i think one of the reasons they
held on to marone was we're going to
keep the bird in the hand
until we know we can get the two in the
bush but but we'll see
and we'll also see whether or not urban
meyer if he takes the job can be a
competent nfl head coach
some people look at it and say i don't
get it it's no different than nick saban
you're a great recruiter
that that isn't going to do anything for
you at the nfl level
well and and we'll see with matt rule
same thing applies to him and we'll see
how he works out after
one year he looks like he's done an okay
job but is he going to win
is he going to win a super bowl in
carolina it's the same thing when you
hire a college coach if you're
jacksonville
is irving meyer who has been a great
college coach
going to be successful at the next level
we've seen it so many times that it
hasn't worked with the chip kelly's and
as you mentioned even nick saban who's
the greatest college coach in history
didn't work out for him so
can can one of those college coaches now
make it work out in the nfl
maybe so maybe not if that's who they
want i think it would be a great hire
considering they do have the number one
overall pick and
he would get to pick the quarterback
that he wants whether that's trevor
lawrence which we presume for so long or
would it be justin fields now based on
the way he played and
and what he's done and the fact that
urban meyer has been at ohio state so
that would be really interesting if that
was the higher and this looks like a
great job mike concerning the cash that
they have next season the salary cap
room
and the fact that all those draft picks
they have however
i paused today when i heard some of shad
khan's comments
that he wants to be in charge that kind
of scared me a little bit like a mini
jerry jones at least jerry has sort of a
football background he did play at
arkansas won a national championship
i don't know what kind of football
background shad khan has and that's why
you hire a gm
and that's why you hire a coach to make
those decisions is he going to be making
a decision on
when the rookie quarterback's going to
play is he going to be making a decision
on who the rookie quarterback they draft
is
let's hear a little bit of shad khan
from earlier today and i'll give you my
thoughts on his
apparent desire to be heavily involved
when we get to the other side
luckily we have a lot of salary cap
availability along with the draft picks
and
obviously the number one pick but what's
evaded the history of the jags
uh really has been a franchise
quarterback and i think what's
unique uh certainly is that we have the
ability
now to make a choice and it's gonna
define the franchise moving forward
he did comment elsewhere during that
session on this notion of having
finals say but you know what sharing i'm
not troubled by that
because every owner does have final say
they run and hide and act like they
don't but they
do they want to be able to blame
somebody else
i think jerry jones biggest failure over
the last 31 years
and let's face it if a guy bought a team
today and tried to install himself as gm
he would be shouted down
by twitter by sports radio by by
espn peacock nbcsn every cable network
out there you can't do it it doesn't
work that way you don't just make
yourself the gm
because once upon a time you played
college football that
that doesn't qualify you to be the gm
but ultimately
these guys do have their finger on the
pulse they do get what they want matt
ryan was an
owner's pick and it worked out in 2008
by arthur blank they were going to go in
a different direction he wanted
matt ryan tuatanga viloa was an owner's
pick in miami
again the owner doesn't come out and say
johnny manziel was an owner's pick
in cleveland they're not going to come
out and say it they don't want to be
perceived as meddling and they want to
reserve the right to blame someone else
for their mistakes so i i think shot
khan is just acknowledging the obvious
at the end of the day it's his team
and he's got to sign off on these picks
and i think it makes it hard
frankly to justify justin fields over
trevor lawrence if you are urban meyer
now i think what you would do is you
would
you would try to flip-flop with the jets
try to grip them that way
slide down a spot pick up some draft
picks and then take justin fields if
that were
what you want to do but they so
desperately need
someone who is going to galvanize the
fan base
and i think that's that's trevor
lawrence that's something they've never
had a guy who's going to be that
yeah like andrew luck in 2012 the guy
who is the
clear obvious focal point of so much
discussion
and when he comes to your town he's
going to sell out all the tickets he's
going to sell jerseys and he's going to
make you money
at the end of the day that's what it's
about you mentioned whether or not matt
rules ever going to win a super bowl in
carolina
i believe frankly that david tepper
doesn't ultimately care about winning
super bowls as much as he cares about
building a team that is competitive
every year and maximizes its revenue
potential
if you hinge success on winning super
bowls you are going to be
upset more far more often than not the
patriots have failed
66 of the time when it comes to winning
super bowls
every year that's not what it's about
it's about having a consistent year and
a year out contender and you hope that
you eventually get close enough to the
door that you can kick it in and win a a
championship and the jaguars
they had the one year in the last 20 the
one year
and it looked like they were on the
front end of something great
and then it all fell apart and now
they're trying to rebuild it and i don't
know i just
i don't i got to believe that urban
meyer when you look at
the health issues he had at florida the
health issues he had at ohio state
and it may have all fundamentally been
driven by stress
that stress that that type a
double positive personality that wants
to control everything
and ultimately can't control the
bouncing of a ball
can't control whether or not a referee
pulls the yellow flag out of his pocket
there's so much you can't control about
football and it gets worse at the nfl
level
that's what drove nick saban crazy
that's what drove nick saban back to
college after only two years
and part of me wonders what's really the
difference between nick saban and urban
meyer
and will urban meyer ultimately say i
can't do this
after getting a couple of years under
his belt shireen
but you do wonder mike if if nick saban
had picked
the right quarterback which was drew
brees obviously as we know instead of
dante culpepper
back then if he would have been a
success at the nfl level
maybe he would have been and that has
been the jaguars problem as shot khan
said they drafted three in the first
round byron left which blaine gabbert
and blake bortles and none worked out
this one looks like one of the surest
things we've ever seen in the nfl and
i'm talking about trevor lawrence have
they picked just the fields he
looks like he can succeed but everyone's
been on trevor lawrence for two years
uh that he is the next coming of andrew
luck and peyton manning and those guys
who were sure
fire number one overall picks that is
going to lead your franchise for a
really long time
so you have a chance to do that in
jacksonville if you take that job
something that nick saban didn't have
when he got dante culpepper instead of
drew brees
yeah and and look nick saban himself has
said within the past few years that he
would still be the coach of the dolphins
if they had taken drew brees there's no
guarantee
that nick saban was going to groom drew
brees into the quarterback he became
there was a reason drew brees was
available as a free agent
the the chargers saw a few years of
breeze and said
we need to do better we can do better
and they got philip rivers and they let
drew brees walk away after a couple of
years following the drafting of phillip
rivers
and and yet look the dolphins picked
dante culpepper with a wrecked knee and
gave up a second round
draft selection to get him over drew
brees
who was free and clear free agent but he
had 26 studs in his shoulder from the
injury he suffered in
in the regular season finale in 2005.
but
that was sean payton and drew brees that
created something magical i don't know
that it's a given
that it would have worked with nick
saban and drew brees and i don't know
that it's a given that's going to work
for urban meyer i think that
that we've i i just think at a certain
level shad khan
is in bright shiny object mode and he is
fascinated by having the number one
overall pick getting trevor lawrence
and then being the guy who can go out
and hire
a name that is on the a-list every year
even though we don't know what that
guy's going to be
if and when he's an nfl head coach and
we reported today he's looking for 12
million a year and people like oh 12
million a year
and look 12 million a year is not
unreasonable in today's nfl and when you
follow where the revenue is going when
you
understand what gambling is going to do
to the value of teams i had someone to
suggest to me not too long ago that
these teams are going to be worth 7
billion or more each before too long
once
the gambling industry really matures and
is in enough states and they start
making money over money over money and
the teams identify the revenue streams
12 million a year for a head coach is
nothing you're paying back up
quarterbacks 12 million a year
coach is far more important than backup
quarterback 12 million a year is nothing
i'm surprised it wasn't more than that
for meyer shireen
yeah absolutely mike i think he's worth
every penny of it based on what he did
in college and what he can do for you in
the nfl what you can think
he can do for you in the nfl if you're
convinced that's the guy who can win
you can win with and so i think he would
be worth every penny of that if that's
the guy you identify as your guy and
that's what he wants
and and you want him you go pay what he
wants and get him in and
and hope that he is the right choice and
if he's not you're going to be paying
him off in a few years
and let me reconcile my two points there
i'm not sold that meyer is going to work
at the nfl level
but if you are sold on him then 12
million a year
is not an unreasonable amount to pay and
it appears that shot khan and the
jaguars
are sold on urban meyer and we'll see
if number one they can sell him on the
job because he still has to decide to do
it
and whether or not he can ultimately
succeed but he will have trevor lawrence
if he wants him and uh the jaguars may
become
a relevant team far sooner than later in
a division that
even though it was very competitive this
year and look you've got deshaun watson
you've got ryan tannehill who knows who
the colts are going to have as their
quarterback but but that that that could
be a compelling division with trevor
lawrence and urban meyer in it
um we talked earlier about the best
openings and i think that we both are in
agreement that it's
jaguars then chargers because jaguars is
the biggest
open slate it's an empty pallet and you
have the cash and the cap space in the
draft picks
jaguars makes the most sense to me we
agree that the chargers is second
beyond that shireen i'm not sure what's
next maybe the jets
you know the problem with lions texans
falcons and and
you know i i try to choose my words
carefully here
this is a reality and i mentioned it
last night on football night in america
as it relates to rich mckay
in atlanta the more layers there are
between the coach and the gm and
ownership
the more the more buffers there are the
more people there
are whether it's jackie used to be in
houston whether it's rodwood and chris
spielman in detroit whether it's rich
mccain atlanta that makes the job less
attractive
and the average fan doesn't really
understand that but what happens is
you're trying to do your job day in and
day out you're trying to run your team
and you've got somebody in between who's
got less accountability than you
that think they know better than you
that is whispering
to the owner and to justify their
existence
they have to look for things that they
can criticize they have to look for
things that they can say they're not
doing it right
we need to tell them to do it
differently that creates dysfunction it
is an
atmosphere it is an environment that
breeds dysfunction
and i'm telling you the most competent
and capable candidates
are looking at those teams shireen that
have
that buffer between the football
operations
the coach and the gm and ownership and
they're saying
if i can take a job where i don't have
that that extra layer
of communication of of complication i
don't want that job
yeah and i love the houston job simply
because you have desean watson
as your quarterback and we know he's a
franchise quarterback we saw it
he's been terrific and no one's noticed
because they've been so bad
and that defense is in need of a
complete rebuild right now it's awful
they have so many problems they have
they don't have the number three overall
pick
they don't have many picks because of
all those stupid trades and laramie
tunsil
frankly was not worth the number three
overall pick it was
stupid and now you've moved on for that
so if i'm going to houston i know i'm
going to have
all those layers as you mentioned and
i'm going to have to have time to
rebuild despite having the franchise
quarterback in place so i tell you what
it's going to take a long-term deal for
me to do that
or i'm going to have to be an assistant
coach who's never had that opportunity
before and may never get that
opportunity again
and i think that's why houston ends up
with a an assistant coach who's never
been a head coach before
because they will want that job thinking
they can rebuild it
and and and do it
over a period of time it's not going to
be done quickly quickly but over a
period of four or five years and are you
gonna get four or five years that's my
question and i don't know that you are
i think they're going to expect you to
win now because they have been
successful over the past few years but
bill o'brien frankly tore that franchise
apart over the last couple years
mike i'd say the texans are the spot
where the 49ers were four years ago
where they had to give six-year fully
guaranteed contracts both to the coach
and the general manager to create the
impression that they're not just gonna
have a revolving door
and fire you after a year or two the
wild card in houston is jackie used to
be the executive ep of football
operations
there there's a sense out there that
he's he's not going to be
as influential and powerful as people
think and the gm is going to determine
his role i'll believe all that when i
see it
because i think there's a broader play
going on here to create the impression
that easter b isn't going to have power
and control but when we see who gets
hired it's going to be obvious this is
somebody that needs to be signed off on
he's going to be able to maintain his
influence
without it being obvious because that
that's the sweet spot
for these folks who have the best jobs
in football where you get paid to held a
lot of money
or you've got a ton of influence where
you can claim credit when things go well
when it goes sideways you don't get
fired
like the coach in the gm that's the best
job to have
that's the job you can have for 15 or 20
years and never get fired and that is
the thing that drives coaches and gm's
crazy
because their attitude is if you're
going to have any involvement in
football
then you you get in the boat with us and
if it sinks
you sink along with it all right
the names that have been flooding out
today we don't need to get into the
whole latherance repeat we know the
usual candidates we know the names that
are going to keep coming up whether it's
robert sala
the defensive coordinator of the lines
eric b enemy the chief's assistant
uh coach offensive coordinator all the
names that we've heard are going to keep
coming up and there's going to be a lot
of interviews that unfold
the real thing for me is when it starts
to focus on who the candidates are we're
too early in the process other than
jacksonville thanks to urban meyer
talking too much we don't know where the
chess pieces are going to go but that
will be
determined hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports